hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and we
are at the Democratic National
Convention in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
and we're about to talk to Democrats to
ask them to pitch us on why libertarians
should vote for Hillary Clinton and Tim
Kaine let's see what they have to say
what is the pitch from a democratic
partisan like yourself to independent
voters for why should they vote for
Hillary Clinton well she is definitely
the most qualified candidate I just feel
like she's going to be the best person
that we can have for our country and we
just need her in the Oval Office her
resume speaks for itself
Barack Obama had no resume when he
started so why should we care about her
resume what's her vision for the future
you have to do that research for
yourself I'm already a convinced Hillary
vote I'm an independent voter who leans
libertarian I believe in social freedoms
and fiscal responsibility what is the
best pitch that you can give to somebody
like me to say vote for Hillary
well it's just Trump and Hillary right
now so I would say to go for Hillary
since she's really big up in the
community and children who we got to
look at Hillary Clinton or TRO Trump is
a demagogue that worships hate and
really does not profess a belief in the
Constitution of the United States the
current Republican Party is just out of
touch we got two horses in this race the
values of Hillary are probably more in
line with some of the things that you
expect yeah but like drone strikes state
surveillance lor she's for war you got
to be in favor of drug legalization
she's against that not standing up for
gay marriage until 2013 the thing is is
that even folks that are actually LGBT
themselves it takes some time to come
around to be able to come out to come
you just say that Hillary is a lesbian
not that there's anything wrong with not
that there's anything wrong with in what
could you say to persuade me to vote for
the Democratic nominee this time around
I'm not going to actually do that
because I am now supporting Jill Stein
he said it's there's only two choices
Trump and Hillary but what about the
Libertarian Party candidate Gary Johnson
or the Green Party candidate Jill Stein
to be honest I'm not really sure they
span Florida my research about them they
have some good perspectives and I
respect their but I just don't feel like
this is the time for us to move away
from the Democratic Party I can't give
my support to a third party candidate
unfortunately in this news cycle or in
this election cycle whereas normally I
definitely would however I do believe we
always need more debating support Jill
Stein and the other candidate Gary
Johnson to get on the stage and debate
with our leaders
I won't our family will not be
supporting Gary Johnson will be
supporting Hillary Clinton I don't know
how long you been in this country but
the whole point of America is to rebel
against your parents nothing will do
that more than voting libertarian I'll
tell you that right now give me the
pitch on why a libertarian somebody who
believes in limited government free
minds free markets socially liberal
fiscally conservative why should we vote
Democratic
well it sounds like then libertarianism
beliefs are counter Democratic but I'm
not sure I don't know if I have a good
answer for that